the Prime Minister today delivering some
hard truths what was once far away now
feels very close I fully understand
public concern now your concern about
the global spread of the virus and it is
highly likely that we will see a growing
number of UK cases a disease that could
soon be spreading freely across the UK
Boris Johnson together with his chief
medical officer and scientific adviser
keen to prevent public panic let me be
absolutely clear that for the
overwhelming majority of people who
contracted the virus this will be a mild
disease from which they will speedily
and fully recover but a responsible
government must prepare for the worst
with the NHS and public safety in sharp
focus
yesterday the Scottish chief medical
officer said that up to 4% of the
population might have to be hospitalized
do you accept that figure and if so how
will the NHS cope with nearly 3 million
people being hospitalized will you draft
in the army if necessary and can you
promise citizens that in the midst of
all this you can keep them safe on the
NHS and the potential pressure on on the
NHS it will be very important for
everybody to think not only what we can
do to prevent the spread of the virus
individually but also what we can do to
avoid too much pressure on the NHS so
when it comes to using services such as
GPS or one-one-one if and and it will be
quite important to be so frustrating
where where possible because I say most
people will unquestionably get through
it and on your on your second point the
army is of course always ready to to
backfill as and when but that is under
the the reasonable worst-case scenario
Boris Johnson's opponents clear where
the priority should lie the NHS needs
support in order to cope with what could
become a very very serious problem
throughout our health service but not
just the NHS under strain this outbreak
could strain all of our
Public Services the government's not
sugarcoating the risks in this action
plan released today all of us are
vulnerable to catch in the disease one
in five of us could be off work sick at
its peak the army could be deployed to
help police the streets and all
non-urgent NHS care could be cancelled
in the coming weeks we might be asked to
work from home avoid big public
gatherings stay away from the elderly
but the message from the government
today is let's all take this one step at
a time the health secretary taking that
message to the Commons if necessary we
will take some of the actions set out in
today's plan to reduce the impact of
absent ease and to lessen the impact on
our economy and supply chains we prepare
for the worst and work for the best the
worst case scenario contained in here
for now just words on a page a severe
prolonged pandemic is some way off if it
comes at all for now then business as
usual for all of us but the question is
for how long
bethe Rigby Sky News Westminster